[Musique]
en gala merkel
ne s'est pas portée candidate à la
chancellerie
16 ans 16 bonne année pour l'allemagne
déjà handicapé par plusieurs bourdes
durant sa campagne le candidat de la cd
ou en a commis une de plus en votant il
a mal plier son bulletin résultat son
vote qui doit être secret ne l'est pas
et je tiens tout d'abord à remercier la
chancelière un green haskell pour son
travail
un candidat est trop stupides pour voter
correctement l'autre pense aux gens
c'est aussi pour ça colle of souls
devrait devenir chancelier en matière de
secret et l'achète et le chancelier
préféré de tous les services secrets
étrangers et les électeurs de gauche
peut-être ont la même question que moi
aujourd'hui si on ne vote pas macron au
premier tour est-ce qu'on va pas avoir
un deuxième tour marine le pen eric
zemmour nous devons refaire des français
d'abord par quel critère c'est facile là
lorsqu'on l'a toujours fait c'est-à-dire
l'appropriation par l'école je me nomme
on me pense tout le temps pour cette
histoire de prénom mobutu dans le pays
qui l'avait nommé à l'époque le zaïre
mobutu il a pris une loi pour interdire
les prénoms qui n'étaient pas des
prénoms afrique finie la primaire place
au congrès le candidat des républicains
à la présidentielle sera choisi par un
vote des adhérents et non un vote
ouverts au public
alors c'est qu'il pourrait participer au
congrès oui oui oui
d'ailleurs annoncé par plusieurs de
personnes qui sont proches de lui son
entourage ses porte-paroles excite
europe ils sont cinq à s'être déclaré
candidat michel barnier philippe juvin
eric ciotti ont eux aussi accepté ce
matin ce mode de départage on remarque
toujours que je ne distingue pas entre
l'islam et l'islamisme mais on ne
remarque jamais je fais un distinguo en
revanche contre l'islam et les musulmans
et leurs marques ça permet que le 4
décembre débat soit clos et surtout
rassembler derrière un candidat d'union
et et l'union vous savez ça ne se
décrète pas l'union ça se construit
musulmans peuvent très bien se détacher
de l'iss hommes et avoir une pratique de
leur religion ou j'appelle moi avec tous
les guillemets du monde chrétien me le
faut le scrutin se déroulera en deux
tours subtilité le parti se réserve le
droit d'invalider une candidature qui ne
serait pas conforme aux valeurs de la
droite et du centre
une clause clairement anti eric zemmour
sims a ainsi coûté je pense d'abord je
suis pas sûr qu'il soit qu'il soit
candidat mais ça c'est de sa
responsabilité en tout cas voilà il
n'est pas de notre famille politique on
sait tous l'ensemble des dirigeants
de l'air se sont exprimé là-dessus il
n'y a pas dans mes couilles il n'est pas
notre famille politique c'est quand même
des emballements aussi autour d'un
zemmour que personne n'imagine président
de la république mais quand même
l'emballement et l'art expliqué joe
bâlois jeunes orange allait surtout pas
parler de ça pourquoi mais ça je le
mènerai pourquoi vous n'allez parce que
j'ai un voudrais quand même non c'est un
fait médiatique pardon le premier
responsable c'est le système médiatique
et notamment le système bolloré qui l'a
promu moi je j'ai populariser cette
semaine une formule que j'aime bien de
quelqu'un que qui était un ami un grand
historien qui fut compagnon de la
libération jean pierre vernant on ne
discute pas recette de cuisine avec un
anthropophage en attendant de sauver le
pays il veut d'abord dynamiter la droite
à budapest il affiche sa proximité avec
marion maréchal ex le pen qu'on doit on
penser ben on va en penser qu'on s'aime
bien et que c'est la vérité si marion
maréchal soutenait eric zemmour à la
présentielle ça sera un coup dur pour
vous 2 pourquoi ce serait un coup dur
quand même c'est une proche quand même
de mal à exister dans les caisses que
vous allez je vous dise et l'air est
devenu depuis longtemps un parti de
notables centriste qui a trahi
l'héritage du général de gaulle 4
l'héritage de georges pompidou qui amène
trahi l'héritage du rpr des années 80
[Applaudissements]